Two thousand years after his assassination,
he is still revered as one of the greatest real,
as in all of history.
Yet his story reverberates as a tale of the dangers of power on bounds.
It is military genius and political skill saw him rise to the position of
dictator for life,
but it all came to a bloody end.
On the ides of March.
In this week's biographics,
we discovered the man who was Caesar Goddess Julius Caesar
was born on either the twelfth or 13th of July in the year 100 bce.
His was a patrician family,
which historically had political sway but was not influential at the time of
Jesus' birth.
His Father Gaius was a prenatal or an elected magistrates,
and it was the governor of the province of Asia.
While his mother or really I belonged to a family of some prominence.
Seizes on.
Julio was the wife of Gas Marius,
who was the leader of the popular faction.
Political movements.
We don't know very much about Caesar's childhood,
but his education included the study of the Greek language and he read the works
of Greek historians in his early teens.
He began attending lectures on philosophy and rhetoric,
showing a keen interest in developing his skills as a public speaker.
At the time,
this was something of a price stability in Rome.
The Roman forum was the center of intellectual discussion and debate in Rome
during seasons youth.
It was there that political ideas were argued out where questions were discussed
in elections,
held any man who has ambition as a master,
the skill of holding the attention of their audience,
and Julius Caesar,
he was showing himself to be a young man of quite some ambition.
Tragedy struck disease.
A household,
though in 85 ce when Ghia senior died,
suddenly the 16 year old Julius was now the head of the family.
He inherited this leadership at the very time that civil war was breaking out
between the popular faction,
led by his uncle Gaius Marius and his political rival,
Lucius,
Cordelia Sula after a bitter and bloody struggle,
see,
like gains the ascendancy.
Gus,
he was exiled to Africa and he died shortly thereafter
with similar now in power.
Those who had ties to Gaius.
Marius were put under pressure,
having married the daughter of a prominent member of the popular faction,
Cornelia the team sees a.
He became a bit of a target,
see little ordered that he break off the marriage and distance himself from
Gaius.
Marius sees a refused and twist prescribed by a similar meaning that he was
marked to the executed.
The 18 year old Caesar was now forced into hiding.
It was only the influence of his mother's family.
The led to see like lifting this death sentence still,
Cesar was understandably of Sula.
He decided to do it,
be safe for him to be away from Rome while Sula road the city sees it now,
set his sights on a military career.
Initially he served under Marcus Minimus,
thermos.
He proved to be a natural soldier serving with distinction in the provinces of
Asia and Cilicia.
In 79 BC,
he was awarded the oak leaves of the civic crown for saving the life of a
citizen in the heat of battle.
Things is rising.
Military Statute led to him being chosen as an emissary to the king of the at
Nicodemus in order to exact a promise for a fleet of ships.
He was successful in its mission,
how rumors spread that he had only managed to persuade the gang by agreeing to
something
defender.
In 78 BC,
he died opening the way for season two to Ryan having left the army.
He began a career as a legal advocate with his inheritance having been
confiscated during the reign of Sila.
He and his wife live a modest lifestyle and the lower class neighborhoods of
Sabira.
Three of his legal representations season began to develop a reputation as a
powerful and passionate public speaker in 75 bce.
While on his way to advance his studies in Greece,
Caesar was kidnapped by Sicilian pirates and held for ransom.
It is reputed that when the pirates told it and they had demanded 20 talents for
his release,
he was insulted and insisted that they increase it to 50 talents.
He was treated well by the pirates and has a relaxed time with them.
However,
the the ransom was paid and he was released.
He vowed to them that he would hunt them down and have them crucified.
He was good to his word raising group of volunteers and overpowering his former
capitalist prior to their execution,
yet the pirates throats carts as a show of leniency for having treated him well.
Shortly after his pirate escapade.
Caesar was recalled into military service he was sending to the province of Asia
and tasked with raising a volunteer force to put down a rebellion.
Upon successful completion of this mission,
he returned to Rome and was duly appointed as a military tribune.
It was the first step of his political career.
Season was not shy about espousing his support for the popular faction,
which had been put down by Sulla years before he took on the prominent case of a
reigning the governor of Macedonia dollar Bella,
who had been closely associated with Suda.
When the trial came,
Caesar appeared at the forum,
the force and vigor with which he rated his argument sweating great public
support in opposing dollar.
Bella sees it was positioning himself as the people's champion.
He was increasingly being seen as the natural inheritor of Marius in order to
head up the popular faction with Suna supporters still in the ascendancy,
however,
Dolabella was acquitted,
but the case had made Julia Caesar,
one of the most conspicuous men in all of Rome.
Caesar loved the prominence that he was receiving.
He began to take on the character of the leader of the Popular Party.
He spoke fluently in the forum both before assemblies and in the courts of
justice.
It is legal role.
He came to specialize in defending those who were accused of political crimes
through his energy and his boldness,
not to mention the strength of logic and reasoning that he demonstrated.
He became the rising champion of the people when Caesar's onto the wife of
Marius Julia dive.
He arranged to hold a prominent funeral for her since the time of the
suppression of our husbands and the potty.
He headed junior,
had lived in obscurity,
in fact,
any who associated with were putting their lives in danger.
Yet the fearless Caesar said there's a flattering funeral oration from the
rostrum of the forum.
He went as far as condemning the ouster of his uncle and producing images of
Marius for the crowd to see that this says Patricia partisans in the audience.
They began to objects,
but they were shouted down by the crowd.
Before long Caesar was delivering another funeral oration.
This time it was his own wife,
Cornelia,
who had died in delivering the oration.
He made the points of praising a family who had been prominent members of the
popular family in both funeral oration.
He emphasized the ancient ability of his family claiming descends from the first
king on his mother's side and from the gods on his father's side.
Following the funeral for his wife,
sees a was appointed as a crestal,
a position which involved performing financial auditing duties.
He traveled to Spain where he served as creatorship and 69 bce.
It.
It said that while in Spain,
he came across a statue of Alexander the Great's,
which caused him to reflect on this life's accomplishments.
To date,
he was now 32 the same age at which Alexander had managed to achieve well
dominance.
In comparison.
He had achieved nothing of significance.
He resolved to change that situation.
Upon returning to Rome,
seizes,
prominence and popularity,
soar,
and being elected to a succession of public offices.
Then in 67 BC,
he was appointed to the Senate.
In that same year,
he married the granddaughter of Sula Palm Payer.
The marriage only lasted six years with Caesar divorcing her when she became
caught up in a damaging political scandal.
In 67 bce,
Caesar was appointed as a formal magistrates.
Around this time,
it began to engage in the popular custom of cementing public favor by staging a
lavish entertainment spectacles.
These included games with wildebeests and gladiators being brought in from all
over the realm.
These extravagant displays serve that purpose of making a extremely popular with
the masses,
but they also put a huge strain on his finances.
In fact,
they punched him into debt.
The only way that you could possibly extricate himself from his financial woes
was by rising to a position of ultimate power.
In 63 bce,
Caesar set his sights on the position of Pontifex maximus or chief priest.
He spends even more borrowed money on popular support and despite being opposed
by two powerful senators,
he won the position handily the following year.
He was appointed as appropriate or pro magistrate and an area of southern before
you could take up the position.
However,
he was required to settle his outstanding debts for this,
he turns to one of the city's richest men,
marcus,
the skinniest crassus grasses agreed to help sees a financially on the basis
that he would in turn,
provide political influence in [inaudible] favor,
sees now travel to Spain,
but he proved to be a successful administrator you have to give to both military
and financial success.
We're tending to rhyme with enough money to pay off all of his debts,
sees a.
He was now in a position to satisfy sites on the highest political office in
Rome.
The office of console when the Romans had gotten rid of their line of kings.
They had vested sea pre magistracy in the hands of two consoles.
These men were chosen each year in the general election.
It was left to the people sees,
would have had no problem gaining the needed votes such while says popularity
among them.
However,
there were a number of influential political rivals who opposed him at the time.
There was a buser rivalry unfolding between two men have great influence upon
pay.
Crassus Bombay was a great military leader while crashes held influenced you to
as wealth sees a conceived of the plan to unite them and they get both of them
tobacco in for consult.
He succeeded brilliantly in his plan managing to create a triumvirate of the
three most influential politicians in Rome,
each of whom was bound to advance the political elevation of the others in order
to secure his alliance with Pompei Caesar arranged for his only daughter,
Juliet,
you enter into a marriage alliance.
Lance with palm paved with the support of crisis and Palm Bay behind him.
Caesar set about securing his appointment to the console.
It's political.
Opponents knew that they would be unable to prevent public support from securing
the console ship for Caesar,
so they set their sights on preventing seizes preferred console.
A man named Lucius from achieving office.
They put forward bitterness.
He was a political opponent to Caesar for the position,
sees a ambivalence,
were elected co consoles for the 59 bce.
However,
Caesar immediately proceeded to ignore his colleague assuming full power in
carrying out measures unilaterally that were geared to ingratiate himself with
the People Caesar was opposed by leading members of the sentence.
One of his famous deponent's with Keto fervent patriot.
He was incensed that Caesar's unilateral decision making at one point sees the
ordered that Keto be taken into custody and thrown in prison as he was being
escorted out by God's another influential senator rose to accompany him.
When Caesar asked where he was going,
he replied to that he would rather be in prison with Keto than in the Senate.
With Caesar seizes.
Control of the console ship was so complete,
so this is supposed to go.
Console,
gave up entirely retiring to his house and leaving Caesar Free Reign
sees a follow dizzier is consoled by reimbursing upon his military career by
achieving great military conquest.
He would ensure that his star rose even higher.
His powerful political allies helped Caesar secure proconsul ship over three
provinces for an unprecedented five year governorship.
He became governor of illyricum in the Balkins Sisyphean goal in northern Italy
and translating goal in southern France sees this first opportunity for conquest
came when southeastern Gould was invaded by a tribe known as the Helvetica,
sees a moved against them with six and agents and crushed them during a fisk
five our battle.
He then turned his attention to the Germanic tribes.
Despite the formidable reputation of these warriors,
the Roman legions managed to defeat them at the battle of Valascus.
By 57 bce,
Caesar had built his army to eight legions,
numbering some 40,000 men.
He knows that channel to subjugate the Belgrade tribes decimating each one
individually before they could unite against him.
The final victory came at the battle of sadness,
by which time season it completely conquered the golf course with his power now
unquestioned within his own territory,
seasoned now began looking beyond known borders.
He set his sights on Germania and pertaining Ya.
In 55 BC,
he built a bridge across the Rhine in record.
Ten days having it dismantled when he recrossed after spending 18 days probing
the countryside,
a similar scouting mission was made into Britannia later that same year in 54
BC,
he returns with a full five legions with the objective of establishing a
permanent Raymond base that the Britains though I had other ideas and they
continually harassed the raymonds with a hit and run attacks strategy.
Still the determination of their leader and the discipline of their rank and
file enabled.
The Romans do systematically hunt down the local resistance.
And as the Britains sued for peace season,
negotiated an annual tribute,
took a swath of hostages,
and then left.
Never set foot on British soil again.
In 53 BC,
a goldish revolts was quickly put down,
but a year later or more determined and better organized revolt occurred under
the leadership of verse and get direct,
say powerful warrior who was determined to kick the Romans out of goal,
set out to crush the revolt with a full compliment of 10 legions.
After suffering a number of losses.
Verse and Gatorade switched to a scorched earth policy that's going to go via
the Romans suffered their first defeat.
There's revenge came swiftly at the battle of Alicia.
The revolt was crushed and get her ex was taken alive and transport a jerome
where it was paraded in a cage like a wild animal.
Then in 47 bce,
Caesar embarked on a voyage to Turkey in order to take care of pharmacies.
The seconds it had been extending his power by over powering a number of
neighboring Roman states with just three legions,
Caesar went directly to the town of Zilla to face fantasies.
The Romans took off a strong position on the hilltop.
The Turkish revolt was put down in quick order,
giving rise to seizes.
Most famous quotes,
Veni Vidi Vc.
I came,
I saw I conquered.
Over the next two years,
Caesar put down rebellions in North Africa and Hispania
during his years in military campaigns,
Caesar sauce to continue influencing Roman politics through his supporters.
In 50 bce,
he met with his old allies,
this and pompey in order to renew their triumvirate alliance.
Over the next few years,
however,
the alliance,
it broke down in 53 bce.
Crassus was killed in battle.
Meanwhile,
Pompei was distancing himself from season about this time.
Julia died during childbirth.
Further fragmenting the relationship between the two men.
When Ross interrupted in and 52 BC,
pompey was appointed to the consult without colleague.
He quickly aligns himself with the ultimate faction of Arris to crat suit where
post to Caesar the following year with Caesar's military conquest having been
completed.
The optimists warns him that if he returned to the room,
it would be immediately arrested for excesses of office during his years as
consult within the city.
They had developed popular factions in supportive both pompey and Caesar.
The lasses follow his attempted to have him voted to the console in absentia,
but the opposition demanded that he first returned to face the music and give up
the commands of his army sees the bulks at least amounts.
He knew it now that there was only one recourse.
He had to march on Rome and claim what he rightfully saw as his.
On January the 10th to 49 bce.
He marched a single lesion across the Rubicon River which marked the border of
his province.
This was an immediate active civil war.
Yes,
there will be my battle Pompei with most of his forces deployed in Spain,
fled to the south.
This enabled Caesar's march on Rome on hindered that he had himself declared
dictator with this top general Mark Anthony as second in command in short order.
He was elected to the console ship at which time he resigned his dictatorship
season.
Now,
so touts in pursuit of Pompei,
leaving Mark Antony and control of Rome.
My now pumping had established himself in Greece and was building a four steam
challenge.
Caesar in 48 bce,
the two armies,
Matt's on the plains of fossil.
This with pompey's forces outnumbering those of of two to one.
However,
Caesar one by employing superior tactics,
Pohnpei,
though he managed to escape to Egypt,
sees a pursued palm bay to Alexandria.
There he was supposed to be handed the head of his adversary who had betrayed
the Egyptians and paid the ultimate price.
Just prior to his arrival in Alexandria,
the joint reload 21 year old Cleopatra had been driven from the city.
She had a self smuggled in diseases presence inside a rolled up rug.
She besieged him for assistance in regaining the throne.
The Raymond Nita saw Cleopatra as a useful future ally integrated to support
that a prolonged Egyptian siege of Alexandria followed.
Czo ordered the Egyptian fleets to be burned and managed to hold off a force of
around 20,000 for several months.
He sent a rhyme for reinforcements and when they turned up,
he marched out to join them in the ensuing battle.
The Egyptians were defeated.
Cleopatra was installed as Pharaoh and after spending a further two months
enjoying her company,
sees a began fee,
return Jenny to Rome.
On his way back.
He even put down a rebellion in Asia Minor.
During his absence,
things had not gone well in Rome,
largely due to Marc Antony,
ms dot managements,
employing great diplomatic skills.
Season managed to overcome a potential navy mutiny and put down a rebellion by
the optimists
season was now appointed dictator for 10 years at the height of his powers.
And enjoying unprecedented public support.
He ruled autocratically.
This goal is great business among the senators who we ignored.
Primary among the dissenters were the two sons of Pompeii,
sexists and miss.
These do headed to Spain,
implemented a revolt that Caesar was forced to travel to Spain to personally put
down the rebellion.
In February 44 BC,
Caesar was appointed dictator Pettius.
During the ceremony,
he refused to wear the diadem that Marc Antony handed to him,
stating that Jupiter was the only for king if the Romans,
Ethan prepared to lead a military campaign against the Parthians.
Prior to his planned departure from Rome,
Caesar attended a final meeting of the Senate.
It was on the 15th of March,
44 bce,
unknown disease at 60 of his most bitter rivals in the centers has come to the
meeting with daggers concealed under that togas Caesar entered the chamber and
proceeded to make his way to his golden chat.
Other designated signal senators,
rules,
directions leapt upon him as the first dagger blow came down upon him,
Caesar was hard to cry out.
Why this violence to avid supporters tried to come to his aid,
but they were blocked by the conspirators within limits,
had been stabbed 23 times.
His final act was to cover his face with his toga so that none would see his
death expression.
Cesar died at the feet of a statue of pompey.
The conspirators wanted to throw his body into the Tiber river,
that they were stopped by Marc Antony.
The announcement that Caesar was dead.
It was met with rioting by the people and to the conspirators were forced to
flee.
The city sees his body was cremated with the Temple of Caesar being built on the
cremation site.
From that point on,
the legend of the martyred Caesar would be passed down through the centuries.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
don't forget to subscribe to this channel for brand new biographies every Monday
and every Thursday.
Also,
I've got another channel that's called today.
I found out it's sort of like biographics,
but way more broad on that channel.
We get deep into all of the details on all sorts of interesting stuff.
Check it out through the link on the screen now,
but if you look into something else to watch right now,
why not check out a biography from the archives or is it al found out video over
there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.